now we're going to step it up now we're
going to step it up
um my sort of avenue to introduce that
is to think about the two kinds of
exponential growth and decay equations
that you've met so far there are only
two
there's exponential growth
or there's exponential decay right what
do they look like what do the equations
look like i said you know
p equals for growth what would it look
like
a e or p naught whichever doesn't matter
a e to the
the power of k t right
where k is your um arbitrary growth
constant proportionality factor that
tells you how fast it's going up right
of course decay works in much the same
way we introduced this on tuesday okay
how does the equation change
what's the difference it's a simple
difference
there's just a negative that's all
now very quickly without you know heaps
of detail what do both of these look
like what do they look like
well
this looks like this right and you've
got your asymptotes
the p equals zero right
and this
looks like the same thing but in
reverse
okay now the questions we've been
looking at have been cashed in terms
which deliberately allow these two to be
sort of the equation that you can use
and off you go right
but the reason why i say exponential
growth in the case of a dot question
mark is because in many many situations
this is not the way
things behave and this is concerning
right because the whole point of doing
exponential growth in decay is to say
aha this is how things function in the
real world they do behave you know their
rates of change are proportional to what
their size is or their quantity or value
etc
so this is rather a problem for us right
to introduce a topic that is all about
understanding the natural world this is
applications of calculus to the physical
world and then to say
sorry you know most things in real life
do not function like this okay now do
you remember what was the example i gave
you when we're looking at decay i looked
at two examples um one was about
temperature do you remember what it was
it was a fridge wasn't it and um i i
pointed out to you the fact that they
talked about the fridge and they said
that the temperature of the fridge was
the same to remember
zero degrees but we were like that's not
the temperature of a fridge fridges are
i think they're four degrees aren't they
right
why did they do it like that well i'll
tell you the exact reason why they
needed it to fit this
right
if the temperature's four for the
temperature were four
this doesn't match this doesn't match
does it if i wanted so you know
capital t for temperature or i think it
was h for heat or something like that
okay this is not tending towards four it
is tending towards zero so they crafted
the question in order to allow you to
use these equations okay
but the problem is
we want to be able to understand
situations where this is not the
situation what if i was to change it to
four degrees
how would that adjust things okay
now therefore to help you understand the
way this works and see why this is a
three unit type thing especially one
type thing rather than two
i want you to consider an example with
me
and as in many cases i'm going to talk
about a population okay so let me give
you a few numbers and then we're going
to build all of the maths off that give
you as few numbers as i can here are the
numbers
okay do you believe i can build a
complicated question off those four
numbers
just watch okay so what do they mean
what do they mean i should get another
color um 2 000 is um
a starting population
i made it up from the size of the school
okay so there you go
when time zero you've got a population
of two thousand that's where you're
gonna go okay but suppose we're in an
area where there are constraints
where they normally are right in terms
of space in terms of like you know food
stuff that's running around that you can
eat okay so therefore let's just suppose
the demographers know that this area
that we're in
has a population limit of 10 000 there's
no way it could support more than 10 000
people in there okay at least not
without destroying all the natural
resources and so on okay so 10 000 is
what the population is growing toward
but it's never going to actually get
there okay so this is our case
uh this is our limiting case if you like
okay
now one more piece of information
suppose we started off with 2 000 okay
but
after three years
we took another um census or something
like that and we found there was a
population of six thousand we tripled
okay
so now i have off of these sort of three
pieces of information i've got three
questions to post to you okay the first
question is can we find the population
as a function of time can we model this
in some sort of uh you know definitive
way like these but we're already sort of
alluding the fact that neither of these
are going to be sufficient okay
can we get a population as a function
time
can we have can we find the population
change
that rate
how that's changing
in relation to the size of the
population
let me say that again and let me ask if
you can explain how i would write this
can we find
how the population is changing over time
in relation to what the size of the
population is
what should i put on the right hand side
what am i looking for
i'm looking for the rate of change as a
function of
the population right that's what i'm
trying to connect to
right
i don't want it in terms of time i want
it in terms of how many people are there
right so therefore i need a new function
we'll call it maybe we'll call it g or
something like that
but it's not a function of time it's a
function of the population okay because
that's what we're expecting in
exponential growth of decay that there's
some kind of proportionality between
these two okay
last question
it took us three years to grow to six
thousand as a population
how long will it take us to go to a
population
there are my three pieces of information
and my three questions
pretty natural to ask now i'm going to
walk you through these in a second but i
wonder if you can get through any of
this on your own steam think about it
i'll give you a clue i drew these so
that you could have a visual cue for
what these look like right
drawing what you know is not a bad idea
here either okay have a shot
we'll see what we can come up with in a
few minutes okay